Hey everyone, it's Michael Btos from
Orderflows and this is a special video
I'm doing on Delta analysis in order
flow. Uh partly because I get I got a
question and from a
user about Delta and you know I I I
thought I've answered it actually before
but again you know I'm specifically
making this video because you know I
answered it and someone else emailed me
another question about it. So um I I do
know there's there's interest in this um
topic. That's why I'm making this video.
And the question is it came in. Can you
explain the first question? Can you
please explain why markets can rise
strongly on falling delta and cumulative
delta and vice versa? It's a very common
occurrence at least in the currency
markets. Um that leads into the question
of delta readings. You know whether you
know this leads me to the question of
the validity of delta readings. Okay.
Um, you know, basically saying, you
know, is delta really valid, useful. Um,
I wrote back, I addressed this in a
recent video as far as the first part,
rising price and increasing negative
delta. Market can rise when delta is
increasing negatively because their
supportive buying is coming in to
bolster the market. I showed an example.
I'll show in this video some better
examples. Then he replied back with
another question. Um, understood. I know
this has to do with limit orders holding
the market even dominant pressure on the
other side. How can this help in our
trading decisions when we are taught to
link rising delta with buying pressure
and thus theoretically upward price
movement? If cumulative delta this when
you get into cumulative delta that's a
whole another topic. If cumulative delta
can be positive or negative on a rising
market, how can using this help? And
yeah, this a very important question
actually
and you know I want to highlight it
actually because I I'm a big believer in
Delta. I do believe Delta can help
traders um you know and but it gets a
little murky. I'll say murky it
sometimes it's a bit hard to get your
head around initially with Delta. So I'm
I'm going to try my best to explain it.
Um the tools I'm going to use in this
presentation is is the order flows
trader software which is the volume
footprint. Um but before I get into it
uh go through a brief disclaimer. This
presentation is for educational
andformational purposes only and should
not be considered a solicitation buy or
sell a futures contract or make any
other type of investment decision.
Futures trading contain substantial risk
is not for every investor. An investor
could potentially lose all or more than
the initial investment. Risk capital is
money that could be lost without
jeopardizing one's financial security or
lifestyle. Only risk capital should be
used for trading and only those with
sufficient risk capital should consider
trading. Past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future
results. Now, I'm not telling you, oh,
because Delta is positive, you go out
there and buy. No. Um, you know, analyze
what's going on in the market.
So, let me uh get a chart up here really
quick. Let me find a good chart to use.
I don't know. We'll just uh Okay, we
Well, since he's talking about currency
markets, I'll start there.
Um, okay. So, what I got here? This is a
eurourrency chart.
Now I don't have cumulative delta on
this chart but let me just throw it up
there.
Um okay so first part of his question um
can explain why markets can rise
strongly on falling
delta. Okay so you really got to break
this question down. Why markets can rise
strongly on falling delta.
Okay. All right. So, why can markets
rise on falling delta? Well, why would
you
have negative delta on a rising market?
Well, let me find let me find a
something to just to show you a better
example, a clear example. Um, so here,
okay, market is this bar. Okay, strong
negative delta minus 200, right? your
strongest negative delta in recent you
know bars. Why is it why is the market
going up? Well, okay, you have
supportive buying. You know, you got
limit orders in here, right? So, what is
delta, right? Delta
is measured, you know, basically delta
is the aggressive buyers in the market.
So, buyers or sellers rather, aggressive
traders. I'm sorry, you know, I'm just
doing this. I didn't create a whole
presentation. I'm just doing this to get
it out. Um, so you know if if my train
of thought sometimes wanders um I'm just
not not doing I'm doing this essentially
live you know it's not scripted or
anything. So you have a bid market's
always bid and offered right there's a
bid and there's an offer. Now people say
no it's not you know the market could be
limit up. Yeah okay general market
conditions there's a bid and there's an
offer. So in this case say the market's
bid at 06 at 6 and a half right. So
there's bid and offer. When someone
sells into the bid they are being
aggressive. they're the aggressive
seller and that registers as minus one
on the delta. If someone buys the offer,
that registers as plus one on the delta.
So when you have a minus delta of 203,
you had 203 more aggressive sellers in a
bar.
So when you got negative delta in a bar
that's going higher, you got two things.
One, you've got supportive buying in
here. So you got 344,
292, 321, 387. Okay? So there's there's
people bidding the market. You know,
they got limit orders in there. Passive
buyers, so to speak. That's why you have
negative delta because there's a lot
more selling going on in here. And then
later, you know, maybe all these people
that were selling it realize, you
know, this market's not going down
anymore and they stop selling. You know,
they say, okay, let's give this one,
they could say, let's give this market
some time to breathe. I know I used to
do that when I was selling the out
of the market and I was pushing the
market lower, you know, when I was
working on the institutional level. I
say, "Hey, that's it. I don't want to
push it any lower. I'll give it a break,
let it breathe, let it come back up
before I start selling. You know, why
would I want to be selling down here at
06 when I'm the reason why the market is
selling off, right? I could pause, let
the market, let some buy and come back
in and then start selling it again to
move the market lower. Okay? So, you
know, as one of my other users pointed
out to me today, it's also, you know,
can be a sign of lack of liquidity. And
so, what happens is the market starts,
you know, the selling pressure eases,
okay?
And you know the buying is still there
on the limits. Okay. But what's
happening now is the selling is slowing
down and it's not stopping. But on the
way back up, you know, people are buying
it and you know the traders that are
realizing the market all sudden start
rallying. You know that we're working
offers at 7, 7 and 1/2, 8 are thinking,
hey, this market's coming back up. I'm
going to pull my offer. Why should I
sell at 700 if I think the market's
going to rally? I could sell it up here
at 10, at 11, at 12. So that volume, you
know, that liquidity is being pulled out
of the market, right? If you ever watch
a dome, you always see people pulling
bids, pulling offers as well as, you
know, placing new bids, placing new
offers. But, you know, as the market is
rallying, you know, sometimes you see,
you know, like in the e- minis, you see
a,000 at 6, you know, 26,000 at 26 and a
quarter,000 at 26 and a half. But as the
market goes up, people are pulling their
offers, right? It's not trading. They're
pulling their offers often times because
they realize the market's going up. So
why should I be selling it at 6 and a/4
when I could be selling it at 6 and 3/4,
you know? So they they'll back off
though
basically and the market will rise up.
So as the market's rising up, there's
not enough liquidity here for the buyers
to buy that's going to turn this delta
from negative to positive.
Okay, that you know I mean if you know
if there's still a big seller in here
say right here at this 291 if there's
another 204 lots then you'd have
positive delta right the market is is
going to trade through there and people
buy another 204 lots and you'd have
positive delta okay but there's not
there there's that liquidity is is out
of the market for whatever reason
okay so you know that's that's the first
part of the
So that's how a market can rise on on
falling or on negative delta. Um on
falling delta. Okay, let me give you an
example
here. You see this a lot in in thicker
contracts. Um thicker I mean thicker
volume. Um let me just see if I
could can't remember if there was a
decent example here today.
What is that? That's the fives. Let me
see in the
bonds. Okay. So, you know, I explained
how a market could rise on negative
delta like that. So, on on falling
delta, how can a market rise? Let me see
if I got a a falling delta in
here. Uh, not really. Let me check
crude. Okay. So, you know, this is kind
of an example, I guess. Um, the market's
rising here on, you know, well, this is
that's on negative delta. You get up
here near the high, you know, it's 800
here in this delta, 88 650 here, minus
170 on the high. Okay,
why it's minus 170?
Because, you know, you got people
selling into these bids, right? Market's
rallying. People are buying up here. You
know, they're bidding the market up.
People, but you know, sellers up here
want to sell it. Boom. They're selling
it. Here, you're still at your high. You
got negative delta, negative delta,
negative delta, negative delta. Why do
you got negative delta? Look down here.
Look at this volume here. Look at this
volume. Look at this volume
here, you know? So, there there's
supportive buying in here. Okay. So,
what's going to happen to this market
next? Right? You got to ask yourself,
well, you have the supportive buying.
Okay? So, is that bullish or that's
bearish? To me, that's bullish right
now. Okay? But you're up here at your
high. So if you're got bullish signs or
you got supportive buying in the market,
you really being expect the market to
rally and keep going higher, what
happens? It just goes sideways. It's not
going anywhere. It's not going higher.
So at some
point, you know, two things are going to
happen. One, you're either going to make
a high or two, you're going to sell off.
You're going to sell off if these
supportive
buyers are basically exhausted. you
know, if they bought all they all they
need and you know, comes in later here.
Okay, so all of a sudden here you had
all the supportive buying it dries up.
I'll say it dries up, but it's you know
it starts to be overrun here and then
you know as you get up here you see boom
more aggressive sellers coming in 700
500 and the market moves
lower. you know, that's how a market can
um rise strongly on falling delta. Oh,
that's not really falling delta. That's
still negative delta. I really want to
address your question
um precisely, but again, it's you know,
today the market
conditions aren't really there.
Um, you know, because you know what you
had going on up there in the in that on
that crude is you hit the high you you
went up to the high on you know sort of
you know it's here is 800 strong here
it's bit weaker here it's weaker you
know New high, new
high. Um, then you get some selling off
there. Again, again, you know, today's
market conditions weren't very conducive
to answering this question.
Um, actually, you know what? Let me look
at the uh S&P 4 range.
off
here. Okay. So, again, you know, it's
not really
showing that um you know, delta
decreasing here.
Yeah, I'd love to show you a picture
perfect example, but um unfortunately
there really hasn't been there really
wasn't one today. But again, you know,
nothing is ever picture perfect in the
market. You know, as a trader, you're
making the best decision with the
information that you have.
Yeah. All right. Well, I'll take a look
at the 10 range really quick before I
move on to the the next part of the
question. I mean, I I hope I should have
been able to answer that
question with my explanation.
Um, okay. I guess this would be kind of
an answer here. How can the market rally
strongly
on falling
delta? Okay, so I got the 10 range
charted here. So, here you got falling
delta 7,000 coming to new high. That's
what you like to see. Then next bar
1,00. So it's dropped off precipitously.
Next bar on the high minus delta. So the
market rallied on declining delta on
falling delta. Why?
Well, what do you got in this bar? Look
at this
volume. 7,000
4,000. And look as as you go back
up, you know what do you got here? 1,200
2,000 900
1,000. So, you know, even though it's
still positive delta, you know, at one
point this bar was minus 3,000 negative
delta. So, early in this bar, there's
some strong selling in here. It's
selling into strong bids. So, you had
aggressive sellers selling down here,
5,000, 5,000, 7,000, 4,000,
3,000. at the end of the bar, you know,
when all the dust is settled and you add
up, you know, you you do the the delta
when you delta's
um being processed each tick. But, you
know, when you look at the bar after the
fact, you know, you see it's the delta,
it looks weaker. It's only 1,000
compared, you know, obviously to the
next bar. But
still, you know, would this be a
stronger
delta if, you know, if this was 9,360
instead of 936? You'd have a big strong
delta. So, you know, the market rallied
still going. It's still going up. The
reason why the delta is kind of a looks
like a weak number kind of deceiving is
because you had a lot of bidding in
here. And on the way back up, there's
not necessarily that liquidity. You come
up here, you got negative delta minus
2,62264. Why is because look at this
volume in here. There's much more being
traded on the bid side than the offer
side. You know, another thing you could
do with the software, you could look at
the actual bid, the volume traded on the
bid and the off the volume traded on the
offer. So, you can see here um on the
offer,
33,000
traded on the bid. Um 32,000 traded. So,
you know, 1,000 more traded on the
offer. That's why you got the positive
delta of 1136. You know, here at this
high, you got more selling going into
the bid. 4,500 sorry um 47 4500 47,000
sold into this bid whereas only 44
45,000 bought on the offer. That's why
you got the negative delta. I don't like
to keep all these things. I could I
don't need to know the actual numbers.
But for me, the headline numbers is good
enough. You start putting up a lot of
that stuff, you get confused. So I had
to pause for a second. But, you know, if
you're interested in seeing what the
actual number was to trade on the offer
and the number traded on the bid, you
can get that information. But again, you
know, what you're looking at is, you
know, this market has got supportive
buying going up. So, even though it's
declining, you know, there's supportive
buying there. There's selling. Yes,
they're selling. There's never more
buyers than sellers, right? For every
buyer, there's going to be a a seller.
But what you're looking at is the more
aggressive buyers and more aggressive
sellers. So the next part of the
question is you know cumulative delta.
Okay I don't really use cumulative
delta. I find cumul personally I've
always felt cumulative delta was
lagging. And when you start going, you
know, I use rangebased charts,
which you know, a lot of people like to
use minute-based charts, but when you
use r uh minute based
charts, depending on the time frame
you're using, you know, your cumulative
delta can really either be lagging or I
don't say make no sense, but be useless.
And again, I'm I'm going to show you
u. So, first I'll pull up a minute
chart. I've got a one minute chart here
in the E-
Minis. Whoops.
Um, okay. So, anyway, so here's the mini
chart. Okay. Cumulative delta right
here. Okay. Well, we'll take it. We'll
walk it back up to when we made the
high. So, you're you're at your high of
the day up
here. You got ratio divergence.
Um, at this point you got very positive
cumulative delta 12,000. Okay, start
selling off. You know, if you're using a
one minute base chart, look at
cumulative delta is is to me no value
because you know it's taking into
account all the other delta for the
entire day. So if you're looking at
delta, you know, it's not going to
change for a long. It might change once
or twice during the session, but you
know, at this point when you're up here
at the high, you're going to have a you
should have a very strong positive
delta, right? The market's not going to
rally on negative delta. I mean, it can,
but generally, it's going to rally with
aggressive buying. You know, if it's a
strong move, it's going to rally. You're
going to have positive delta when you're
at your high of the day. Cumulatively,
again, I'm not saying, you know, like
here's your high of the day, you got
negative delta, but the cumulative
number, it's a buildup, right? It's
cumulative. It's the entire um sessions
number. So you get up to the high, it's
12,000. Okay. So what's it going to take
to turn it negative? It's going to take
12,429 more sellers than buyers. Okay.
But if you're using a one minute chart
and you're only trading a,000 2,000 lots
in a bar, that's not going to happen,
okay? In one bar, it's going to take a
long time for it to catch up. So you're
at your high, you start selling off,
okay? Okay, your high is
39. You get down to 37, you got a lot of
negative delta in here, you know, but
it's mixed in with some positive deltas.
You know, you've come off two points
still at positive delta.
10,000. Okay,
later later. Still positive 14,000 now.
13,000
10,000. You know, let's see where it
really comes off here. Makes a move down
here. Okay, so it's selling off, right?
What's happening? You're getting selling
coming in. You got bars with negative
delta, 200, 500,
1,200. You know, you do have some
positive delta in here mixed in, but
again, you know, more negative delta.
Cumulative delta is just
decreasing. So, you know, maybe you can
track cumulative delta on on some sort
of average like, oh, it's decreasing.
You know, that's a good sign. Cumulative
delta is going lower as you're moving
down. Okay, I could understand that. But
for me, it's if you're just looking at
cumulative delta and just looking at it,
it's well, it's still positive and
you're moving lower. You've sold off
from 39, now you're trading down here at
33, still got a fairly healthy positive
delta. Um, that's why I'm not a big fan
of cumulative delta in my analysis.
Again, I I know people that
that use it in their trading and, you
know, they're they're happy with it, but
again, for me, I I don't find much value
in it.
Um you again you know different ways to
approach the market. Okay lots of
different ways to approach the market.
So you know here what is this Euro
currency a 15-minute chart cumulative
delta right here. You know you as you're
going lower you got negative delta
negative delta you start rallying a bit
you still got negative delta there not
much change in
it again. You know you hit a new low
very strong negative delta your
strongest negative delta. Then you rally
from 91 all the way up to to the close
and you got, you know, negative delta
still, but you already rallied, right?
So, how's it catching up? It's not
really catching up.
Um, so you know, again, you know, so
back to the eight range chart. Okay,
so well,
okay, let me find a different chart.
Okay. So again, you know, cumulative
delta, you know, sometimes it when I say
it's lagging, right? You got to take
into effect, you know, it's a cumulative
number from, you know, from a certain
point in time. Okay?
So, you know, if if you're looking at
came with the delta at 1:00, you
literally got the whole day. And, you
know, it's still negative, right? You
know, it's trying to get positive in
here. We're starting to rally a little
bit, but it's still negative. You get a
bar, you know, you you got a bar with a
positive delta, then a little bit later,
you got a bar with a negative delta.
They're sort of washing each other out.
I don't, again, I'm not a fan of
cumulative delta. I know people that are
and you know that that's great but you
know for me personally I I just don't
find much in it in my own style of
trading. Again you know other pe
everyone's got their own style of
trading but that but again you know
that's
the
that's the issue but you know that's the
uh that's the thing that I have with
with um cumulative delta. So, NASDAQ.
Okay, here's cumulative delta.
We're, you know, we're selling off here.
Okay, we got positive delta. This is 7
in the morning. You got positive delta
all morning. You're selling
off. You know, your high is is much
earlier. You're rallying up, rallying
up. Then you're coming down. Finally,
you're starting, you still got positive
delta. You're coming down into your lows
down in here. Still got positive delta.
Come down here. Now look, come
cumulative delta is nine way down here
already. Way down here at the low. Flips
goes down to negative. But then the
market turns. Buying comes in right
here. And you know, you had first one
bar you had minus 30 delta. All of a
sudden you got positive 220
again. You know, then here it's still
positive as you're making new lows.
And you know, even though you're getting
some negative deltas in here, the
positive deltas are just, you know,
outweighing it. So, yeah, I mean, people
will say, well, you flipped. You went
from negative delta of 30 and look at
this big rally you got. Yeah. But then,
you know, here you got negative delta,
negative delta, market turns to positive
delta. To me, it's like using a moving
average
essentially. So, anyway, um, moving on.
Next part of the question is his
reply. Uh where is it here?
So how can it help with your trading
decisions? We're taught to link rising
delta with buying pressure. Thus
theoretically upward price movement and
vice versa. Okay. Cumulative delta can
be positive or negative on a rising
market. Again I just explained why I
don't particularly like cumulative
delta. I like bar delta. Um but again
I'll give you perfect example. I mean
the whole thing of divergences goes
around focuses around um delta, right?
Well, the reason you have a divergence
is because you have a new high with a
negative delta or a new low with
positive delta. So a new high with
negative delta right here. Okay. And
what's it telling you? You know, what's
a divergence is when price and an
indicator go in opposite directions.
Right? You're at a high, you expect
positive delta. So now you're at a high,
you got negative delta, it's telling you
selling pressure. Selling is coming into
the
market. Okay. Up here at this high, you
got selling coming into the market.
Okay. When you're at a low and you got
negative delta, yeah, that's great.
You're at a low, you expect to have
negative delta, right? You expect the
mark, you know, as the market is is was
going down, right? You expect to have
the negative
delta. Um, but anyway, let's talk about
this move here really quick. Okay, so
you're making this move lower on sort of
declining negative delta and actually
turns positive right here. And you're
thinking, hey, why is this market going
down? All right, with negative
delta with sorry, declining negative
delta, it looks like the delta is
actually getting
stronger
and it is, right? I'll say it is, but
you know what's going on? So, you get up
here at your high, right? You got it. It
changed, right? It went from positive
delta to negative delta. got this
divergence cuz it's a new high with
negative delta. That's what a divergence
is. A selling divergence, buying
divergence would be the opposite. It' be
a low, a new low with positive
delta. But um but anyway, you're coming
down here 2005 2,800 then 800 - 18 plus
365. Well, think about what's happening
in the market. Okay, as you're going
down, there's still selling pressure.
the selling pressure is just getting a
little bit weaker. And in this case,
there's not much. There's still no net
buying coming in here. Max delta is
still zero. It's still all min delta. So
this bar, this next bar, actually at
this point in time, I thought this is
where the market was going to turn and
just sort of go sideways. I didn't
expect it actually come all the way down
into the low. You actually had some
strong positive delta in here. It was
1968. There was a lot of buying in here.
You know, for a while you had a buying
imbalance here. This
2839 even here at
3,000. But then the selling came in. All
right. Selling came in. You ended up
with again minus 18. You know, that's
not a big number. You know, minus 18 is
if there was an extra 20 lots here, this
would be uh or sorry, if an extra 20
lots traded on the offer, this would be
a positive delta. But selling came in.
There's just enough on the bid to turn
it negative delta as the bar closed and
then you formed a new bar and again you
know there was some buying came back in
here 2797 right here you know that's why
you got positive delta so people were
looking for this market to turn here
actually rather than down here buying
was coming in people were buying this
offer you know and even turn it bid
buying these
10s for a good you know to the tune of
27.97 okay but And you know what? For
whatever
reason, people stop buying. Um, again,
I'm not here to say why they stopped
buying, but I'm just reading what's
happening. All of a sudden, selling
comes back in. There's not much on the
bids down here, 900,
1,953 that, you know, if there was, you
know, if there was, if someone had
another 500 lots on this bid and it got
hit sold into, you'd be looking at a
negative delta here in this bar. But,
you know, it it's positive because there
was a lot of buying early in this bar.
But, you know, what's the key to
takeaway is you can see how this delta
selling is is, you know, it's getting
kind of weak down here. And actually in
these bars here, you're seeing, you
know, you it's like those this those
scenes in the movie where the guy's on
life support and you look at his his
heart monitor, you see the blip, you
know, the occasional blip. That's what
you're seeing in here. You've seen the
occasional blip with the buying with the
max delta 1968 1970. So, you know,
there's some buying interest coming into
the market. Finally, you dip down to the
low. You hit the low. Boom. Strong
negative delta 4,200. Because down here,
buyers are stepping up down in here.
Okay? And you can't take out the low.
Again, I'm not saying because you can't
take out the low we bounced, but you
know, people are coming in here buying.
You know, is this considered smart
money? I don't know you know it's
supportive buying in the market 3,000
6,000 but you know these people that
were buying these 97s you know earlier
buying this uh sorry 597s buying these
um 10 and 3/4 10 and a halfs down in
here you know maybe they're seeing the
market selling off and they're thinking
I got to get out and these are you
know quote unquote trap traders and all
a sudden they're turning sellers down
here but they're realizing hey maybe I
should have sold here as the market
starts bouncing back up. But again, you
know, there's supportive buying coming
in here, but there's still there's the
selling interest, you know, whether it's
these people that were buying in here
looking for the market to pop up here
or, you know, or whatever, you know,
maybe people who knows people doing ARB
or something or people just thinking the
market's going to we're hit down at or
low. Maybe we're going to keep selling
off. I don't know. That's not important.
What's important is I see this buying
coming in. Then more importantly, I see
this bar turning price action and the
bar turns up. So the bar, you know, so
these sellers that were selling here all
of a sudden are realizing, you
know, I sold and the market's not going
any lower. At some point, they're going
to capitulate and, you know, look to get
out at some point. You know, everyone
says, you know, and I know some people
say as as soon as you sell, you're a
buyer because at some point you become a
buyer. But you know, all these people
that were buying down are selling down
in here at some point, you know, as the
market starts railing are going to cut
their losses and start buying. That's
why you often times you see, you know,
markets turn like this with the strong
negative delta and then the buying come
in, you know, over the next couple bars
as the market starts to rally and more
people are thinking, hey, you know, we
finally putting in our low, you know, we
got supportive buying down here. So, all
these people that are selling it got to
start covering and rally back up again.
Again, I'm that's my own analysis.
That's how I use Delta. And to me, it's
very effective whether I hope that
answers your question. Again I again I'm
not a big fan
of cumulative
delta but again it's you know delta is a
tool right don't think you can um I mean
I don't know I'll say don't try to
devise a whole trading system around
because you can um you know I've done a
lot of work with delta over the over the
years and again it's something that's
very useful but again it's don't take
the numbers on the surface sometimes you
got to drill
a little bit deeper to understand what's
actually going on, right? I mean, you
got negative
delta, you know, on a bar that's going
up, you might you should be asking
yourself why. You know, you're at a
swing high, you got a positive delta.
Ask yourself why. Why do you got
positive delta? You know, these are
questions that you should be
asking. You know, what's going on in in
the market?
Every time you make a high or a low, ask
yourself what's going on. You know,
don't just take it for granted that you
have a low, you should have negative
delta and but you got positive delta on
the low and thinking,
oh flow doesn't make any sense. No,
there's a reason for it, right? There's
a reason why you got the positive delta
here is because, you know, you had some
selling into the bids, but then you had
people working offers here still trying
to keep the market down. That's why you
got negative delta here 207 208 you know
114 that as you know as the market
starts rallying back up you know because
you know as the market goes lower right
there's going to be people working
offers on the way down if they really
think the market's going to go lower
they're going to stack up their offers
they're going to work more offers but
then the market snaps back you know boom
they're lifted and you're going to end
up with positive delta because
aggressive buyers are coming in off the
Hope. So anyway, um I I hope that
answers your question. It's uh again
it's it's something it's a tool that
delta is a tool. Use it, you know, try
and think about what's happening in the
market. Okay? Yes, when a market is
rallying, you should have positive
delta. Yes, when a market is selling
off, you should have negative
delta. Um when they diverge, you know,
that's times to, you know, that's the
time to pay attention to what's going
on.
So again, I really hope this answers
your question. You may have to watch
this video once or twice more. Again,
I'll if it's still unclear, I'll try and
write out a
formal presentation and do it. But
um I I really do hope this this makes it
clear. Sometimes I try to explain
things. I probably make things a bit
more complicated to uh to people. But
again, you know, once you understand
Delta, right? Like here, this is the
Delta Scalper. It runs on a normal bar
chart,
but you know, you could use delta in
your trading. How can it help you in
your trading decision is? Well, you look
for things in the delta, right? And you
know, I got this indicator. I hate to
use indicator as a tool to tell me when
the market when I think the market is
based on my analysis of deltas when I
think the market is changing from a
supply driven market to a demand driven
market. And you know, this morning in
the Euro currency, this is how it looked
on the on a bar
chart. you know, gave us nice sell here,
another nice sell there. Here's a buy.
Didn't really work out. There's a buy on
a red bar. I'm not interested in it. A
nice buy on a green bar and it did pop
up a bit. So, you know, again, you know,
it can be very useful if you know how to
apply it. So, you know, thanks for
watching this video. Hope I made sense.
I hope I didn't confuse people even
more. I have that tendency sometimes.
Um, so again, thanks and uh let me know
your thoughts in the comments and um
subscribe to my YouTube channel. This is
my website orderflows.com. Thanks
everyone.